[music]
I spent a lot of time thinking that things would not get better.
I felt very weird, I felt very out of place.
It could've been me killing myself when I was 13.
I know what it feels like to be in an environment
that feels oppressive. Throughout middle school I always felt different
and not normal. I was unable to come out in my time as an
undergraduate. High school is a place where so many people
feel isolated. That's why I ran from you, I was running from myself.
[music]
Elizabeth:
You can get to a place where you love yourself, where you feel good about who you are.
Meredith:
Things will get better with every year.
Rodrigo:
It's getting better every day.
Alison:
Because it does get better.
Sitraka:
Walk purposefully to a place -- THE place -- where it will get better, for you.